a British chef went temporarily deaf for
two minutes after eating a plate of the
world's hottest noodles this is a story
that's why it is British chef what
they're really deaf after eating the
world's hottest noodles apparently the
noodles were 5000 times hotter than
Tabasco sauce that is some hot noodles
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I thought that is that's Tony
one of our cameramen Tony why is that so
funny hot noodles
[Laughter]
that's right Tony the the noodles we're
talking about are really really hot hey
Conan do you like hot noodles sure I
like hot noodles do you like long hot
noodles I do actually I love spaghetti
so I like noodles that are long and hot
so um do you like your long hot noodles
to be dry or like wait well you got to
have sauce on your noodles your hot
noodles so I would say wet yeah oh
definitely wet yeah yeah absolutely I
prefer a long hot wet noodle uh-huh
uh-huh and so do you like your long hot
wet noodles to be soft or like I don't
know it may be like the opposite of that
that's a fair question Tony I prefer my
noodles al dente oh yeah meat you
absolutely al dente all the way so I
guess you could say that I prefer a long
hard hot wet noodles all right Todd's
here good levi's all right good Roy okay
pawpaw good you're here everyone's here
good good Tony I'm curious why is the
whole crew standing with you oh no no
reason no reason okay guys check this
tub yeah hey Conan I got one final
question for you these long hard hot wet
noodles were talking about you like to
put them in your mouth of course I do
yeah guys that's that is a really silly
question I mean what else are you gonna
do with long hard hot wet noodle yeah
and he's right I mean I love pasta
really like all right till wolf it down
I'll take big bites I guess you could
say that I love the feeling of long hard
wet noodles in my mouth I'll let my
noodles long I like them hard
I let them hot and I like a wet and I'm
definitely I just love to shove them
right down my mouth
[Laughter]
this segment brought to you by the
double entendre Council of America
additional funding provided by Petra
five-word and pitched in salami that's
right just some unease in general which
was O'Keeffe museum and penis and
boobies international
[Applause]
you